para todos é muito obrigado por me terem
convidado para poder partilhar também
estas ideias e factos
às vezes é uma coisa fantástica pode
partilhar não se gasta multiplicam se
eu vim aqui falar vos isto que me fosse
na espanha vê agora lutando aqui a
portaria se eu falar a palavra economia
quem é que se lembra de funcionar
exatamente é o problema e vocês não têm
culpa é que isto não devia ser um tópico
que ressaltava reina sozinho
indiretamente dizer a mim faz lembrar
possível ver que a economia é que a
principal culpada
as pessoas achavam que com a união tem
nada a ver com funcionários e portanto o
tema da minha apresentação é porque
precisa a economia da cidade
um dos primeiros problemas que se coloca
é isto que a economia e às vezes quando
faço estas apresentações perguntar às
pessoas que comigo que prossigamos ponto
que eu apesar de ser doutorado no sangue
o que é economia
ainda assim vocês reagiram rapidamente
com ninguém não tem nada a ver com fosse
lá em português a palavra economia tem
vários significados mas entre elas têm
dois que em inglês tem palavras
diferentes um desrespeito é isto que é o
lado material da viva crescimento
econômico hoje os agregados financeiros
aquilo que nós associamos falamos uma
economia companhia no brasil está
pujante economia economia a palavra
economia também significa se econômico
também significou pensamento econômico
significa é que o que as pessoas que
pensam sobre este assunto dizem que aqui
temos uma mesa pt tem uma mesa que não
existiu anos nisso karl marx josé edson
pitta e johnny cash games seria
seguramente um bom toque seus dias em
casa então é inglesa economics e nem
carne e causa-me primeiro fla economics
esses condições e eu faço sempre está
pronto que a economia quer pensar em de
facto explica é mas a verdade é que se
nós somos os livros
não há um consenso crescente sobre a
economia e isso deve voltar também para
um problema talvez haja pensamentos
únicos mais dentro da quadra é roleta
também para aquecer a economia
nós só pensarmos para que serve a
economia vai voltar a crescer 62 que
serve para criar riqueza
os pensadores econômicos se antão sem
conter idéias e no final os autos que
nós ficamos à espera é que a sociedade
sejam mais capazes de criar riqueza
nós tínhamos muita economia também uma
idéia promover eficiência e produtiva ou
seja se nós tivermos um planejamento
econômico em fight nós vamos conseguir
ter sonhos mais produtivas e vamos
conseguir ser mais eficiente a nossa
vida ser também para aumentar o conforto
material
esta aliás é uma referência clara ao
primeiro usuário
o crescimento da riqueza da guarda o
material da vida pressupõe de facto que
nós consigamos obter mais conforto
material que está uma casa toda
simpática saído com desenvolver as
nações e que já entramos num campo que é
um clube mais dúbio porque a palavra
desenvolvimento e isso mesmo a
literatura sobre estes assuntos discute
não é sinônimo do crescimento as
palavras não são interrompidos e que
vocês vêem uma imagem isto para vossa
informação é toc que é um dos países
mais desenvolvidos no mundo ao menos um
dos países com maior crescimento do
mundo um dos países mais ricos do mundo
e fica assim eu tenho às vezes
perguntava pessoas neste tipo van e
seções se criam que a terra velas
ficasse assim muitas vezes não não não
quero que a minha terra por exemplo vila
real se transforma em toque ou então se
nós não queremos que vila real se
transforma em tóquio temos que pensar
que sentido é que nós queremos dar ao
crescimento do villarreal ao
desenvolvimento do avião mas a estréia
que conhecer para desenvolver
o problema é que nós vamos continuar a
fazer perguntas
são perguntas que às vezes não são
feitas e infelizmente são muito pouco
feitas nos cursos de economia que é e
para que serve tudo isto é os quais
entre os todas aquelas características
que inicia que serviria a economia para
crescer tudo isso e eu acho que muita
gente acha tudo isso faz sentido 11 se
nós conseguimos melhorar a saúde não é
só uma condição sine qua non para a
nossa existência e nós não tiveram sou
temos uma vida muito mais precário e no
limite morremos vamos ganhar todas mas
vamos adiando a aumentar a educação é um
dos traços civilizacional extensivo
terminavam que cada vez mais informação
mais contínuo mais capacidade de
raciocínio as pessoas eo crescimento
econômico desenvolvimento econômico a
comoção material deve servir também para
isto para nós aumentar em função das
pessoas
muito ligado constrói do sul aumentar os
preços médios vida e pensem bem nisto
que ser nós acumularmos riqueza material
se na prática não tivermos a ter pessoas
que consigam viver mais anos e com
melhor qualidade de vida ao ferimento
e eu só entrei aqui eu exemplo e fiquei
aqui três países o japão que é um dos
campeões nesse aspecto portugal somos
nós estados unidos porque é um paradigma
mudou o mundo portugal
as pessoas em portugal em média vivem
mais anos do que o resultado dessa vez
para aquecer do crescimento econômico
se nós não conseguimos acabar com a
pobreza sabem bem como a pobreza é uma
desgraça que efetuou um ovo mas nos 55
minutos
surpreendemente mais nos países
subdesenvolvidos nos países
desenvolvidos mas com essa imagem mostra
vem
mesmo em países desenvolvidos mesmo em
países ricos mesmo fez mais reclamou a
pobreza continua a existir
aumentar o emprego seres humanos sempre
tiveram vontade de ensinar a trabalhar
ao contrário do que muita gente faz crer
que o trabalho é uma é uma chatice ser
humano que caçar o ser humano que a
plantar estava a trabalhar para sua
sobrevivência mas tirava algum benefício
mais ato do trabalho
mas se nós envolvidos o trabalho está
muito mais à tomizawa muito mais
civilizado
nós continuamos a precisar trabalhar
depois é que o desemprego é uma tragédia
tão grande por para o ano todo com um
crescimento no nosso rendimento pessoal
nós temos um crescimento da nossa cidade
da nossa vida no nosso sentido rio em
franco crescimento econômico deve servir
também para que nós consigamos aumentar
ou diminuir o crime e violência não faz
muito sentido estarmos acumular bens
materiais
vamos fazer com que o país seja mais
rico e ao mesmo tempo continuar a
prosperar o crime ea violência na
sociedade promover a liberdade ea
democracia
se olharem para o mapa do mundo e virem
a distribuição da riqueza
há países que têm boa riqueza mas estão
muito longe de ter livrado estão muito
longe de ter democracia observado vai
funcionar em uma sociedade desenvolvida
será uma sociedade livre e democrática
respeitar a sustentabilidade ambiental
isto é uma regra que tem tem sido muito
discutida e muitos tentam pôr em prática
mas temos que olhar para este fato com
muita atenção nos 90 pra nada
transformarmos coisas cada vez mais para
o nosso gosto conforto acabaram de
disputar o posto natureza não aumentará
subiram para que alguns países mais
desenvolvidos do mundo
podemos pensar em votar mas temos que
pensar também nos países nórdicos são um
bom exemplo que ocupa
talvez melhor tínhamos conseguido fazer
em termos ser humano
há muitos casos subiram para aquecer
toda a riqueza acumulada
se nós chegarmos à fase da vida em que
não nos resta mais nada
se não ficar sozinho enfim o que estou
aqui tentar dizer é que nós temos sempre
que ter uma meta e essa meta não é como
ar
não é que seja essa meta é ser um sonho
e quando fãs anos pra que queremos que
seja temos que ter sempre esteve aí nós
queremos crescer
nós queremos acumular nós queremos ficar
mais ricos países a nassau os próprios
indivíduos se formos capazes de com isso
promover a possível e é provável que
olharmos para a história
vemos que nem sempre essas coisas andam
de mãos dadas
infelizmente nos últimos anos dentro da
ciência econômica desde o final do
século 20 com grande com grande
confiança responsável estudar
diretamente as relações podem então ser
entre indicadores de funcionar e as
variáveis tradicionais da economia para
finalmente sermos capazes de conduzir as
economias em direção do que ela sempre
iam ter que provar que era pra nós
precisamos de funcionar e não torça o
nariz porque me fosse dado não é uma
coisa impossível hoje a uma bateria de
indicadores que podem ser usados há um
conjunto enorme de cientistas nesse
momento é estudarem as formas como nós
podemos ouvir a sociedade e todos esse
estudo tem continuamente surgido nos
provam que nós podemos ver com grande
capacidade ociosa podemos depois
construir indicadores por exemplo é
possível nacional bruta é uma
possibilidade de construir um indicador
que vai muito para além do crescimento
econômico e que englobam conjuntos
menções depois postas na prática vidas
nos conduziram muito mais a funcionar
temos também o roubo atravessou apenas
uma voz lá está disponível na internet e
grega estatísticas estudos têm sido
feitos ao longo destes anos sobre as
relações entre as variáveis sociais
variáveis econômicas e funcional
e podemos também avaliar o impacto das
políticas econômicas na funcionar nós
quando discutimos política econômica não
nos podemos esquecer qual é o fim último
da economia
o fim último da economia volta thiré
promoverá possível e portanto nós
queremos relembrar as políticas
econômicas no bom sentido
nós temos que ser capazes de perceber se
aquelas políticas econômicas vão ser com
o centro de salvamento possível
tudo o resto são mais para chegar a um
fim e o fim é possível isto obriga-nos a
consultoria e econômicas que explique as
relações entre economia funcionar e nós
já temos algumas noções sobre os eua por
exemplo aquela moça entre riqueza e
funcional que nos mostra que a curva é
positiva mas com rendimentos marginais
do céu ou seja a mesma que nós nos
tornamos mais ricos enquanto divisão
enquanto nações é cada vez mais difícil
traduzir o trecho voluntariosa
empréstimo vai estar
temos por exemplo aqui outra ideia do
que o nosso nível de velocidade tendo na
nossa biologia das nossas métricas das
nossas condições viva e das nossas
atitudes ou temos ali uma equação que
nos remete para a ideia do que o finado
tem a ver com sucesso - as expectativas
e com o status social
tudo isso são e portos têm sido
instalados têm sido usados por si ou por
economistas por psicólogo neurologista e
estes estudos todos têm conduzido a
algumas conclusões que tem que ser
incorporadas nos meus econômicos
uma dessas conclusões é feita a
adaptação quer sejam para acontecimentos
positivos que seja para acontecimentos
negativos ser humano mostra uma grande
capacidade de adaptação e portanto nós
devemos ter isto em consideração
nomeadamente quando o sujeito potter as
pessoas pensam que vão ficar feio pra
cima a maior parte das vezes não
conseguem manter essa facilidade durante
muito tempo o efeito de comparação
não tem nada a ver com seus invejosos ou
não olhamos muito pouco avançaram olhar
a avaliação que nós fazemos da relevado
é sempre uma avaliação relativa
as coisas só tem valor se forem
enquadrados no atual contexto histórico
social e institucional
e portanto é que vocês vêem essa
televisão por exemplo
vocês não podem dizer em abstratos e
roma houve momentos em que ela foi
fantástico hoje paulo 5 euros ganhar
algum peso encosta
mais uma vez o efeito das expectativas
há uma noção clara que a nossa
satisfação com a vida tem muito a ver
com o lance que nós fazemos diante
daquilo que eram as nossas expectativas
de que os resultados com os obtidos no
entanto tentando manipular essas
relações mas também podemos controlar um
pouco a nossa possível e ainda uma coisa
muito importante
as diferentes áreas da nossa vida não
são substituídos por meios não são
perfeitamente substituídas
todos nós precisamos de emprego e de
sucesso profissional
todos nós precisamos fazer férias
momentos em que não estamos a pensar em
nada
todos nós precisamos nem estar material
da riqueza para termos levado para
podermos acelerar as coisas precisamos
que os vemos que todos nós precisamos do
feitas ações efetivas
agora imaginem alguém que está no
contrato houve
imagine alguém que passa a vida inteira
nas caraíbas olhar o mar o mais certo é
que ao fim de 11 anos sucessivas essas
orientações completamente estarão em
todos os dias a olhar para a marca de 90
o inverso
tinha que me a sua china com dinheiro se
não tiver amigos eu não tiver tempo para
olhar total mar se não tiver um sentido
profissional uma realização pessoal eu
também não faz sentir nada vai dar certo
essa foco nas suas moedas
nós temos que encontrar um equilíbrio
nós enquanto indivídio e nós enquanto
sociedade e isso é muito importante
nem tudo que nós fazemos conseguimos
obter a nós estamos condicionados
posicionado e por isso muitas vezes
caímos no chamado tapete higiênico
telefônico em que estamos a correr cada
vez mais a trabalhar cada vez mais
deixando para ganharmos mais gostaram
mais à frente vamos chegar mais longe
vamos ficar mais clientes ea nossa
sociedade
em outra área de estudo que tem sido
muito utilizada esta rua santa
felicidade e protegerá as empresas
clinton com aspectos ligados à criativa
também a programação tem constatado se
as pessoas tiverem moto e mi maior se
sentirem bem se sentir incluído no seu
trabalho vão ser muito mais produtos
nós fizemos essas análises com rigor com
seriedade e percebemos que este é o
caminho
nós vamos conseguir livrar políticas
econômicas e outras institucionais na
direção da sociedade
nós vamos poder eventualmente desenhar
constituições tinha regras fundamentais
da sociedade que nos permitam sermos
mais meios na busca da nossa confiança e
podemos propor novos indicadores de
desenvolvimento
neste momento já temos o rap 4110
primeiro a capacidade que um país tem de
produzir possível com a exposição que
faz o curso e um dos países que pontua
melhor nisto é costa rica com poucos que
têm conseguem produzir muita ansiedade é
pilar fias podemos distribuir o gol e
ver onde é que as pessoas em média vivem
mais anos com fosse lavar e aqui por
exemplo alguma correlação com o
rendimento destes países
mas as relações não são mais uma vez e
finalmente uma coisa muito importante
que eu estava também vocês pensarem e
refletir sobre isto é que é que o que é
a sociedade do 1 não significa
necessariamente que possa ser combinado
com a sociedade os outros e nós temos
que encontrar aqui um equilíbrio entre
aquilo que é a nossa busca de glóbulo
cidade com a busca da felicidade dos
outros e por isso a sociedade como um
todo e ver com a nossa busca e nossa
busca interfere com o senado como um
todo e eu aqui para os dois eventos
o dac é o senhor que vai caminhar é um
senhor que é um viajante civil o garoto
viaja apenas viagem
o mais sensato porque já é difícil ok
qualquer coisa que acontecer a sociedade
é que percebi há milhares de anos por um
tempo descansando os coletores controlar
a gente já imaginava fazer mais nada
senão viajavam caiu finalmente as
regiões
há muitos estudos mostram que as pessoas
que têm algum crédulos e ou sentem mais
felizes porque encontrou uma relação
espiritual da espécie no lado negativo
visto quantas guerras ao longo da
história da nba têm sido feitas em nome
das cozinhas e portanto nós temos que
encontrar um equilíbrio é que o clube
promove a funcionar e que o que é
compaginável com a sociedade
finalmente voltando ao ponto de partida
isto tudo tem que ser enquadravam não só
mas também dentro da ciência económica
assim achamos que chegou a um dos ícones
mais proeminentes na questão do the
economics of apenas 1hora britânico
possui delas se é e está em queda livre
de estudo quando volta a pôr a tônica
claramente naquilo que no início da
economia e no início dos pensadores
os pensadores clássicos da economia
tinha a certeza que comia e funcionarão
duas palavras que o trabalho sempre
junto obrigado